I'm Instagram don't post photos of food
that is something that you can put on
your snapchat stories but if it's
something that no one really cares about
don't put on your Instagram because
people just gonna get annoyed with your
account on social I never posed like
millions of selfies in one day because I
know that bothers people even on
snapchat if you post many times a day
it's kind of annoying once a week maybe
once a day just not like 10 times a day
it's the thing I've never posts on
social medias naked photo of myself
one thing I would never do social media
is posting nude whether it be my own or
somebody else's nothing that's a primate
d'Alene Commons is bad because they know
that they didn't want that there I've
deleted comments yeah I deleted her
comments I've had friends that who text
me later texting with his formal of like
why did you leave my comment and you
kind of uncomfortable situation I got my
down on snapchat but I never contact him
I had posted something on my story and
he saw it and then he commented on it
and like he sent me a direct message but
I just like blocked after that my
parents don't follow me but I thought
like here Tim I'm not gonna phone even
see you that'd be done
and